[Music]
oh good very good no but oh I see
don't put shaking on my resume it's on
mine
great killing it
alright so Adam Olympic medalist like 15
years of since I set foot on the ice
your number one tip for me here today oh
it's just it's confidence
oh well crap fake it till you make it
you know I have to admit I came here
strong I wanted to you know have like a
gorgeous turtleneck and and a glove
moment these skates aren't the fashion
return Jay ice that I was hoping for so
I think it's like more on like broaden
your horizons like maybe patent leather
blue is really gonna be in maybe that
year 2020 I kind of think it well it's
kind of a glacial Phatak glacier moment
they don't compare to your outfits on
the ice these skates no all right and
then I also I was kind of wearing this
turtleneck there's a moment I remember
of Margot Robbie training for I Tanya
where she wore a turtleneck so I wore
this yeah and then I realized I don't
know if I want to be bringing a Tonya
Harding energy here today here I don't
know if I want you to bring that energy
I believe yeah okay here we go again not
the look of a skate that I wanted out of
this nice they look a little like steel
toe boots it's a little bit like the kid
who was just trying to make the Mighty
Ducks hockey team but he didn't have the
right gear yet that's the vibe I'm
feeling you have beautiful skates your
skates are actually our et colors golden
black I did this thank you yeah you're
welcome
yes thank you Adam yes I'm standing
still that's what I have going for me at
this point move what's the first step to
moving to skating with confidence okay
so here's the thing I think like if you
want to be a skater you're gonna like
skate every day right you're gonna get
good at it but if you're gonna skate on
the go which I feel like you're doing
sort of an in-and-out situation where
the
this is you you're trying to skate
you're trying to impress someone right
yeah I have a date the holidays yes
right and you're like I get laid from
this and so you're not gonna get laid
going like this right he's gonna send
you right to Cedars it's gonna seem like
wow that's that's a mess I don't want to
clean up exactly yeah which in the
dating world I've heard that a million
times you know so I've got a skate with
confidence yes on my occasional skating
moment yes first mm-hmm
so the first step is that when you're on
your skates you actually want to keep
your weight sort of in the middle of
your foot so you're the back of your
heel oh I'm doing this very wrong man
I've been all weight in the toe so when
is forward when you're on your toe
that's when people start like tripping
over their toes right no and look at you
did a full beat today I'm not about to
have that dragged across I do I thought
if I have anything I have a contour yeah
so the first thing we're just gonna do
is like we're gonna just have our knees
exactly everything I'm doing everything
you're doing I don't know what I just
start going yep no it's good
that's because you're a good student
thank you yeah so when we're relaxed
like this this means that like if we're
off balance we can always catch
ourselves right because that's the same
thing in life right sometimes life
throws you off yeah I'm fine but we're
not we're locked up are you kidding is
skating the therapy I need it today yes
yeah you're welcome
we don't want to freeze up let's move
forward absolutely okay that's a career
move okay so we want the weight in the
arches of our feet not the toes not the
heels okay yeah so then we're gonna bend
you'll push from that same point of
reference in your foot so right from the
middle right
wait is in the arch of the foot you want
to glide what step two
okay step two is obviously we're out
here we're trying to impress we're
trying to like we're trying to get
eyeballs on us look at me look at me
yeah I didn't wear a turtleneck for
myself no this is for the audience I
need a 10 out here yes thank you so you
need to know how to do a trick right
obviously so the way that we're gonna do
this is we're gonna do a two-foot spin
so the way you want to do a two-foot
spin is you're gonna march in a circle
okay is it like this I'm a lot slower
than you that was the speed is blinding
the g-forces they're just yeah it's cold
near that's the window so you're gonna
do that and then once you gain a little
bit of momentum you're gonna actually
kiss your toes together on two feet and
it'll help you glide while you're
spinning so no matter what somebody's
getting a make-out session and today Oh
100% are you kidding
I've never skated and not wanted to make
out look I'm not that confident yet can
you give me the end goal 100% yes okay
so I turtleneck obviously yeah so I'm
gonna march around in a circle and then
I'm gonna kiss my toes and bring my arms
and like that that's happening towards
the end I was trying to do that oh I
just caught you
because toe is our own hook I was trying
to do that the whole time just keep
spinning just keep sitting good maybe we
can speed that up in post yeah you know
it's so funny it's like when I touch
your shoulders I can feel the tension
you can do it my caps and all the way
through oh yeah yeah like a lightning
rod of attention Wow again okay here we
go
we're just okay we're gonna March yes
we're marching and then we're good not
bad not bad
here's the thing I didn't spend doesn't
if you have 19 more years of practice
okay you will absolutely get it I'm sure
so I'm gliding yes but how do I look
even a little bit cooler what step well
obviously you need a trick because you
can't just show up the trick
first of all the first tricky pulp is
that II came you know I'm here try
complete second trick is you need an
actual element so I think one that might
be easy but also impressive okay so it's
called a pivot so in a pivot you pivot
around the toe that you put into the ice
so for in this case I'm gonna put my
left toe in the ice and then from there
I'm gonna move around my toe just like
that all I'm hearing right now is Ross
from friends going back
okay very good
no but so then you see like when you get
really good at it then you can go back
or you can do it backwards like okay
backwards yeah stab in witters just my
left one yes your left stab no the other
wait what around and you're still
backwards right but still toe you're
just been momentum is good I did the
backwards of my foot off yes that you're
too good of a student it's like you are
I'm like and now so the toe yes now
we're gonna just move backward from me
yeah you've got a really lean I'm really
leaning into it like a squat no that's
okay in a way where I'm is dramatic okay
yeah well you know what
that's what if you're on a date with
somebody you want them to think that's a
tribute well that is a dramatic person
very good are you kidding me okay thanks
I'm doing it stuck the landing
that is good oh she's gone and she's got
but Adam if I can't achieve one or two
mm-hmm
what's just a way to look good a fake it
till you make it you've had to be judged
so many times on this 100% here's the
thing I've gone into a competition and
been like oh baby it's not gonna happen
for you so the way that I go around it
is that as long as I feel like I looked
good then I can still walk away be like
that was a success okay right well a lot
of the time it's about that big finish
yeah I've seen you you land in front of
the judges absolutely give me the step 3
so I think the step 3 is that we know we
try to stop with pizzazz and if that
doesn't go well then we just and we have
our signature pose you know see for this
you know what at the end of the day you
don't have to be moving you can just go
stationary all right give me a horse so
mine would be something like this I do a
stop
and that's my post because my left side
is my good side you know you always it
the good side yes because my right side
somehow like that's where all the fat my
body goes so my left side I'm okay here
left side strong side yeah Suman zoom
out thank you
okay are you ready what's the face that
you're doing give it to oh I'm just ya
know this is Australia this is the face
I'm doing this one right because I don't
want to unsettle my botox right so I'm
just kind of leaving that like that and
then like that's it are you smiling or
are you more of a I'm sorry I'm looking
down because I've sort of a larger
forehead than I shed for my body it's
like my cross to bear so I look down a
little bit shrink your forehead also
don't move it
since I shown you and giving you every
tip I have I would love to see your stop
with ending pose my little toe right now
is like am I still alive Oh both my
pinky toes AG no I'm not this is dead
serious comment I've thought about
cutting them off not today but like in
general throughout my life I just
thought like just cut it off yeah that's
brave no I'm taking that in yeah I'm
hearing it and I'm now I feel I'm
surprising you show me okay coming in
and sticking the landing mm-hmm see this
is what I love that was flawless because
you didn't need to stop you just went
sort of with momentum and you
immediately showed off the best part
about your skating
thank you your face it's the best part
of my skating - are you kidding you know
what I don't look down here because like
this this makes me look like eight
months pregnant draw the eye up draw the
eye up
honestly I don't know if today was how
to skate with confidence it was how to
pose with confidence yeah absolutely
okay now I still don't know how to stop
Adam so I'm just using you that's fine
Adam thank you so much I feel I'm
skating with confidence
[Laughter]